president Trump's political rallies
often have supporters chanting lock her
up referring Taylor e Clinton and her
use of private email at the State
Department now we're learning the
president's daughter and senior adviser
Ivanka Trump also used personal email
for official administration business her
emails to White House aides cabinet
officials and personal assistants may
violate federal Records rules major
Garrett is at the White House with the
administration's response major good
morning good morning as you said John
personal email account government work
that was certainly a topic the Trump
inner circle knew a lot about in 2016
Hillary Clinton references throughout
that campaign ad yet Ivanka Trump right
here at the White House used a personal
email domain to conduct government
business that revelation came from a
Freedom of Information lawsuit filed by
a left-leaning government watchdog group
now this private domain was used by
Ivanka and her husband Jared Kushner
like Ivanka a senior White House adviser
and from this private email domain
Ivanka reportedly sent hundreds of
government related emails during 2017
the White House learned of all this last
fall now a spokesman for Ivanka's ethics
Council said in a statement quote while
transitioning into government Ms Trump
sometimes used her private account
almost always for logistics and
scheduling concerning her family the
Trump campaign and like-minded
Republicans attacked Hillary Clinton
relentlessly during 2016 for having a
private email server at her home to
conduct some government business while
she was Secretary of State
subsequently some of those emails were
deemed classified it is unknown if any
of Ivanka's emails will eventually be
deemed classified now Gale this is one
topic House Democrats when they take
control next year might well look into
House Republicans did not give Hillary
Clinton much benefit of the doubt on her
private email practices they may use
that is to say Democrats the same
skepticism when it comes to Ivanka more
to come on that Thank You major